[Musik]
hey leute wir haben richtig hunger
bekommen nachdem ihr was süßes gezaubert
haben muss jetzt irgendwas herzhaftes
her und ich habe gedacht ich nehme euch
jetzt mit durch das rezept weil es total
einfach ist schnell hergezaubert und
meistens hat man die zutaten auch zu
hause und hier sind auch schon wir
benötigen kartoffeln brokkoli und möhren
außerdem gouda käse das brauchen wir
auch später noch zum überbacken
hier habe ich natürlich knoblauch und
zwiebeln senf muskatnuss das ist
optional
außerdem butter und mehl für die
mehlschwitze nachher salz und pfeffer
der klassiker außerdem gemüsebrühe und
mich und ich bereite jetzt zuallererst
das gemüse vor
dann tue ich das auch schon mal direkt
in die auflaufform gar nicht erst groß
drum herum quatschen sondern direkt
anfangen und danach zeige ich euch die
soße
[Musik]
so die auflaufform ist gefüllt schön
bunt und das gehen wir jetzt aber
erstmal an die seite wenn wir machen
jetzt mal richtig leckere soße dafür die
könnt ihr auch für andere aufwerfe
benutzen ist so ein bisschen universell
und ich gebe jetzt zuallererst die
butter in meine schüssel und darin
dünnste ich zwiebeln und knoblauch an
schon die mittlere stufe benutzen
[Musik]
nach zwei minuten das ist ganz schön
gedünstet das ganze ist jetzt ein
bisschen glasig und jetzt sorgt unser
mädchen später für diese bindungen damit
die creme halt ein bisschen cremiger ist
und nicht so flüssig die gebe ich jetzt
in einem schwung mit dazu immer noch
mittlere stufe arbeitet das ganz kurz
ein 30 40 sekunden und dann kommen seine
flüssigen zutaten dazu
[Musik]
nachdem alles miteinander verbunden ist
einmal aufkochen lassen das ist wichtig
für die bindung und jetzt einfach rüber
zum auflauf und darüber gießen
[Musik]
und natürlich noch ordentlich käse und
ob ganz ehrlich liebe ich übertreibe
immer leicht ihr könnt mir schreiben
diese ihr käse lied macht das immer so
anhand dieser these images je mehr
images in einer reihe umso mehr liebt
ihr käse ist würde mich meint christian
keser verrückte toller song bisschen
drauf ja natürlich muss ich auch schick
aussehen und ich habe den ofen schon
vorgeheizt auf 200 grad ober und
unterhitze und er packt ihr das bis der
käse goldbraun ist dann sind es auch das
gemüse schön durch und ich denke das
dauert so um die 30 minuten aber sehen
uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
jetzt sage ich nur noch guten appetit
weil was bleibt mir sonst noch übrig
oder ich bin mir sicher dass wir das
noch machen will
aber das klang jetzt so aus dem aus dem
drehbuch
oder aber sie sagen mir drin es sprudelt
und wir drinnen manchmal diese sätze
soja oder auf jeden fall ganz viel
freude beim nachmachen guten appetit
könnt es euch und schreibt mir gerne
euer feedback wenn es dann mal nach
gemacht hat in die kommentare
übrigens es gibt der die funktion der
glocke hier auf youtube dann müsste
einfach die glocke aktivieren und dann
bekommt ja auch mal mit wenn neues video
da ist und seitdem also die erstmal das
wird bekommen colada oder wenn die 25
leute die erste schreiben
ich find's cool die funktion ich nutze
sie selber auch und von daher wünsche
ich euch jetzt ganz viel freude in
wunderschönen tag und bis zum nächsten
mal auf titel sketchen tschüss das ist
nur der rat von ihm also tschüss bei
punkt 12
ich bleibe so dass seine böse gemeint
ich finde toll
[Musik]